أن أشتريها لي هو منظر طبيعي دائم التغير
[موسيقى
] يمنحني حرية التعبير عن نفسي في
حركة Expressman على أي حال فزت
باسمي Harry وأنا مدرب باركور
وبعد أن يتحدث أو يرقص ، فإن
لعبة الباركور اللحم البقري هي مجال للمحاولة
للعثور على التحدي والتغلب عليه ،
نشأت كراقصة ولكن بالنسبة لي لم أشعر أبدًا
أنني أستطيع التعبير عن نفسي بحرية
بالطريقة التي أردت أن أرقص بها بمجرد
أن رأيت الباركور أسرتني على
الفور تبدأ في رؤية
المدينة وبيئتك  في نقطة كانت فيها
الجدران والسكك الحديدية ذات يوم حواجز ،
أصبحت فرصًا للقيام بشيء
جديد ، فإن
[الموسيقى] تقدم
دبي الكثير للممارسة
في مدى تكيفها وتغييرها
طوال الوقت ، لا
يقدم موقعان عمومًا نفس الخيارات بالنسبة لنا
[موسيقى]
تعد منطقة دبي للتصميم وعلى
وجه الخصوص الكتلة هنا
مكانًا رائعًا وملهمًا للوحة المتنزه
، فالمستويات المختلفة تسميك
لاستكشاف ارتفاع أكبر قليلاً
تختلف ممارستي على مدار الأسبوع
أحيانًا أخرج ، أشعر بمزيد من المرح ،
أحيانًا أجد مكانًا جديدًا
متحمسًا وأنت تتجول في المرسى ، لديك
كل الأعمال التجارية حولها تحاول جميعًا
أن تكون فريدة جدًا وهذا يوفر
لنا منطقة كثيفة
من المواقع الأصغر التي نوفرها  لقد
تنوع المدرب كثيرًا هناك
يا رفاق عندما وصلت إلى دبي لأول مرة ،
أحد الأشياء التي أحببتها حقًا
أنني تمكنت من السير على الشاطئ
ورؤية الأشخاص يمارسون الرياضة
بجانب المسار ، هناك توازن جيد هنا
مع وجود  أسلوب الحياة الجسدي يجعل
الأشخاص النشطين ينتقلون من
سن مبكرة عندما نكون في مجموعة ،
إنها حالة ارتداد بعضنا البعض
للعمل معًا لبناء
أشياء مختلفة ، كل شخص لديه أسلوبه الخاص
في الباركور ، إنها طريقة رائعة
لدفع نفسك إلى ما هو أبعد من حدودك العادية
، أعتقد أن
مكانًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
ينمو فيه المجتمع ، سوف ينقلب أمام هذا
الشيء ، تصبح المدينة مكاننا
لتدريب مكاننا على التواصل الاجتماعي في
مكاننا للتطور  نفتح أنفسنا في أي مكان وفي
كل مكان يصبح مكانًا لنا
للتسكع وممارسة
[الموسيقى]
لك